it is a great concert benefiting a
fantastic cause the 12th annual NF hope
concert is set for Sunday and here to
talk more about it our Jeff and Melody
lipo founders of the NF hope concert
along with Emma their daughter who's the
inspiration for all of this and it's so
amazing because it is 12 years now yeah
and you guys have raised more than one
million dollars in that time yeah I
think we're actually breaking a 1.5
um already this year and probably will
exceed that obviously at the end of this
Sunday's a concert that is amazing it is
such a great show you have local
performers and tell us who's on tap this
year we have a great list so we have
Clint Holmes is back after a while we've
got Michelle Johnson who's an amazing
Jazz Singer locally and Martinez from
Bat Out of Hell a great lva grad granted
desantos Kai Brackett who's been with
Barry Manilow for years and the cast of
cocktail Cabaret plus a couple surprises
okay and where and when and how can
people get tickets it is this Sunday at
the at my range of the Smith Center the
easiest way to get tickets is just to go
to thesmithcenter.com NF hope all right
takes you straight there damn I want to
talk to you because you're really sorry
all right we've talked to your parents
now Emma you really are the inspiration
for this fundraiser that is looking for
a cure to neuro fibromatosis right which
you were born with so what can you tell
people about it
um I can say depending on how severe it
is it doesn't
affect you at least if it does you
shouldn't let it affect you at all yeah
you've been super strong obviously is it
is it gratifying and exciting to see
this concert get bigger and bigger each
year and it's exciting to see it get
bigger but
sometimes I just wanna I like looking
back and seeing sometimes I do get a
little embarrassed at my old self but I
I do like to see how I've grown and
become more mature than running down the
aisle way to dance during a song listen
you have what I don't know I didn't see
any of your previous interviews but
you're amazing now and I think you're
going to continue to be amazing and
continue to raise money for a tremendous
cause congratulations on this event I'm
really excited for you thanks so much
all right so let's remind people again
where they can learn more about this it
is the 12th annual in F hope concert it
is this Sunday starts at 2 p.m Myron's
at the Smith Center and again all you
got to do is go to
thesmithcenter.com to get your tickets